music music heard of it
yeah told me about it I think sound is
one of the first census that you really
use doesn't it I mean we're making music
we're hearing music when we're in the
womb did haven't even seen anything yet
you know it's it's kind of a big deal
imagine what life would be like without
any sound but imagine what a movie would
be like with that sound you know kind of
boring but when I think about your art I
think about it's very collage base to me
there's kind of all these different
pieces of words coming together like an
exquisite corpse like sounds commune you
know you think you've got one tip when
it smears into something else
yeah I'm able to recall things just by
hearing my voice interpret them so so
what I do i do do jot it down actually
now now that I used to just do it by
memory you know when you learn to me
laugh to me okay
and I got literally hundreds of these
things
I'll come up with lyrics at all I don't
write songs like that the lyrics are
just sort of a necessary evil it's
likely the last part of the process I
mean after I had all the musics done
then I'll finally you know sit in front
of like the microphone for ten hours
going word by word eventually the
feeling is supposed to be like oh this
thing comes out naturally like as if it
was one solid performance my songwriting
process is hand-in-hand with the
recording process so in a sense whether
I actually realized these visions that I
that you're in my head you know they're
they don't really necessarily come out
right because I'm erasing them as I lay
them down
I like the fact that I'm still not in my
comfort zone ever and and I managed to
feel ill at ease with all aspects of it
I never think I may have felt like a
rock star once I said sadly I can't
remember anything most of the times I
don't I don't feel like a rock star I
feel like a person that's reliving there
and they're naked at school nightmare
maybe I thrive off of that insecurity or
something